hello i'm tom hiddleston and i play
loki hi i'm willie mitsaku and i play
hunter b15
hi i'm google and barcelo and i play
ravona renslayer
and we're taking the buzzfeed quiz to
find out which
marvel hero and villain as a combo we
are
first how would your friends describe
you
chill eclectic vibrant loyal
clever or ambitious you are pretty
clever tom
yeah i would say vibrant
okay um yeah definitely
loyal probably not very chill i probably
could be maybe i should cultivate more
chill
i feel like you gotta go with eclectic
yeah
okay okay okay
i feel like my friends would pick either
loyal or
maybe vibrant you're so vibrant women
you are vibrant okay what do you think i
think i'd either be vibrant or chill
if something crazy was gonna happen like
i would follow you
yes right you pick either vibrant
vibrant
choose a marvel actor to fight alongside
brie larson robert downey jr samuel
jackson paul rudd chris hemsworth or
elizabeth olsen i mean for me looking at
this it's got to be samuel
jackson especially if he's wearing that
purple hooray
i think i would want to fight beside
relarson it's got to be her
the only person i actually have never
thought alongside is paul rudd i've got
to go for paul
i only met him and for a very brief time
that's the new experience right who
doesn't love paul rudd
if you could have any super power what
would it be
super strength telekinesis i can't
remember what that actually means
manipulate objects from a distance
without touching them
with like matilda yeah invisibility
shape-shifting x-ray vision mind
manipulation
but when you look at translation what is
that like so you get someone else to do
what you want them to do
you're at the wheel of their of their
mind but do you know inability is pretty
cool
i agree i think invisibility would be
amazing now i'd want someone to do
exactly what i would prefer to do all
the time shake shifting you could become
anything not just invisible right you
could become
the wind or something it's actually
better because you can make yourself
invisible by becoming a very small thing
like a an ant or a frog on the wall
i fly on you yeah shape shifting is
pretty great i'm gonna go with shape
shifting i think so too i'm gonna go
with my manipulation
choose a tv show to watch during your
downtime
grey's anatomy shit's creek one division
bridgeton the bachelor or law and order
svu the thing that i did kind of binge
was bridgeton i do love a love story i
have to say the only one of these shows
i've actually seen is one division i saw
one division i thought it was great
shit's creek i apparently is hilarious
catherine o'hara is in it
okay i'll go for shit's creek i'm gonna
go fish chips creek as well actually
because i haven't seen it and i just
i need to catch up pick an avenger to
save from
thanos's snap peter parker doctor
strange
bookie barnes shuri group sam wilson
this is a deep dive now i know i don't
know if i'm ready i mean i just love
shuri
she's just the best i feel like she's
going to save the world from global
warming
and everything sherry is great i'm again
i've been thinking my slightly eclectic
way about this
the person you save from the snap is
going to change
reality it's going to change the future
does the end of end game happen
depending on who you pick mind blown oh
yeah i still think shuri i've just
thought of the other th
there's some sort of brotherly feeling i
have towards peter parker because he's
played by tom holland
he's the new more flexible th
they're generally more athletic to you
so i'll probably
do that yeah choose a weapon to wield
into battle
vibranium shield dark magic hammer
tesseract full body armor bow and arrow
i'm gonna go for dark magic it's
powerful it's more powerful i'm gonna go
with the hammer
sorry whoever holds this hammer if she
be worthy she'll possess the power of
thor
i'm gonna go for the familiar you know
if it ain't broke don't fix it the
tesseract
and finally choose an iconic moment in
history to travel back to
the moon landing queens live a concert
performance
the march on washington muhammad ali's
1965 boxing match against sunny liston
the boston tea party the invention of
broadcast television good heavens
where are you going i mean queen's live
a concert this is what i was going to
say freddie mercury does the deo the
iconic
oh yeah yeah
i think i'm going to go for march on
washington users got to
i got black widow and ultron
i have been reliably informed by the
buzzfeed quiz
i am a combination of spider-man and
loki
and mine says that you like your
independence and prefer to do things by
yourself
and like ultron you're a little bit
misunderstood and built to protect those
that you love
i feel like that is exactly right i feel
like that's
spot on you're brave loyal and a
natural-born leader like zemo you're
incredibly smart and just a little bit
cunning i love it
i love it i think it's true i feel
there's something very accurate about
this quiz
as i say spider-man is the new th a new
more flexible more athletic
generally more superior th i'm proud to
be associated with him
loki will be swinging through the
streets of manhattan shooting webs from
his fingers
i feel like we all learn something i
feel like we don't without each other